now to Brazil we're campaigning of in
this for Sunday's presidential runoff
election is being wrapped up leftist
Challenger and Luis Ignacio Lula de
Silva won the most votes in the first
round but not enough to beat the
far-right incumbent Jaya bolsonaro
outright
it's been a polarized and sometimes
violent campaign far-right incumbent
president Jaya bolsonaro holds a last
rally in Rio de Janeiro as Brazil heads
into a final election round on Sunday
are you we don't want to return to the
past and to corruption
[Applause]
we want to preserve peace work
and progress
for leftist Challenger and former
president luisio Lula de Silva an
election win would mark an incredible
political comeback after a stint in
prison on corruption charges that were
later annulled he won the most votes in
the first round and is holding his lead
into the runoff
the election could decide the fate of
the Amazon rainforest as president
bolsonaro has rolled back protection and
promoted deforestation Lawless election
promises include sweeping environmental
reforms
other key election issues have
highlighted the polarization in Brazil's
politics from the country's economy and
struggling Health System to gun control
that bolsonaro has loosened throughout
his term
I will vote for bolsonaro as he put
forward the right to self-defense which
I consider the most sacred thing for my
family my children
[Music]
to the far-right president's term can't
come soon enough
I will vote for Lula to preserve
democracy and to restore our rights
bolsonaro and his allies have repeatedly
alleged without evidence that Brazil's
electronic voting machines can be used
for election fraud opinion polls show
bolsonaro is likely to lose in Sunday's
runoff but his unsubstantiated claims
have raised fears he may refuse to
accept defeat